[Music]  how that I'm here on the covenant making  history I am blessed to serve with my  wife my heart building a new life for  2000 families I told you I would get a  Lynchburg  so until we see each other again you  very much ugly number please  you've all sacrificed so much to be here  and be a part of this thing we're doing  [Music]  this crew is made up of couples it's the  first ever large-scale colonization  mission and everyone back on earth is  really grateful for your hard work  your courage  we're making history here  this is weed while the odds of finding  human vegetation this far from Earth who  plan on it you hear that  what nothing no birds no animals nothing  [Music]  what happened here  [Music]  what's happening  you're breaking up  all of this to start on my wife  what is it  holy  Jaroussky eyes open  [Music]